مات زوجها وسجن ابنها ومات الاخر بعد ان
اتهم باضطرابات عقليه ثم تعرضت شركتها
الانتكاسات كبرى لكنها وقفت امام ذلك كله
وحافظت على مكانه ماليه مرموقه في سوق
الخرسانه والحديد في هونج كونج كونج هي
واحده من اكثر النساء ثراء في اسيا كما ان
عائلتها بين الاغنى في هونج كونج مع ثروه
طائله تقدر ب 14 مليارا وثمانمائه مليون
دولار فما سر هذه الثروه ولدت كونج في
الصين عام
1929 ثم انتقلت الى هونج كونج في عام
1947 حيث لم تكن حياتها جزءا من الحديث
العام في المدينه هناك وعندما كانت في
العشرين تزوجت من كوك تاكسينج الذي كان قد
انتقل مع اسرته الى هونج كونج بعد احداث
الحرب العالميه الثانيه في عام
1969 شارك كوك كلا من فون كينج هايشاوكي
في تاسيس شركه
لبناء العقارات والمساكن تزامن ذلك مع
رغبه الحكومه ببناء مدن جديده فسجلت
الشركه نجاحات عديده بقياده رئيس مجلس
ادارتها كوك فبنى العقارات الفاخره
والمكاتب عاليه الجوده وتمكن من تحقيق
ثروه تزيد على مليار دولار وبات من اغنى
شخصيات هونج كونج في عام
1990 توفي كوك عن عمر يناهز 79 عاما بسبب
قصور في القلب ليترك ارثا كبيرا لاسرته
التي ضمت السيده كونج وثلاثه ابناء وثلاثه
بنات وفيما لا تدرج البنات على قائمه
الايداعات كمساهمات استحوذ ابناء تاكسنج
الثلاثه والتر وريموند وتوماس على 26% من
الشركه وتولى والتر منصب التنفيذي في عام
1997 تعرضت العائله لحادثه كبيره حيث تم
اختطاف والتر على يد زعيم عصابه محليه
ودفعت الشركه 80 مليون دولار لتحريره لكنه
اصيب بعدها باكتئاب تحت اداره
المجموعه ايضا المجمعات متكامله ذات جوده
عاليه وواسعه النطاق في المدن الرئيسيه
بالاعتماد على التقنيات المبتكره والطاقه
المتجدده بعد 18 عاما من تراسه لمجلس
الاداره ابعد وولتر عن منصبه ومنح منصب
المدير غير التنفيذي لاصابته باضطرابات
عقليه كما ذكرت اسرته وتولت كونج رئاسه
مجلس اداره الشركه تحت اداره كونج استمرت
الشركه في بناء بعض المباني الاكثر شهره
في هونج كونج بما في ذلك مركز التجاره
الدولي المكون من 118 طابقا في عام 2010
وهو اطول مبنى في المدينه
بقيت كونك تشرف على اعمال الشركه لكنها
تخلت عن منصب مجلس الاداره في ديسمبر 2011
حيث تولاه توماس خلال السنوات اللاحقه مرت
كونج بانتكاسات جديده ففي عام 2012 حكم
ولداها توماس وريموند بتهمه الرشوه وقضى
توماس خمس سنوات في السجن كما توفي وولتر
في عام 2018 بعد اصابته بجلطه دماغيه
اليوم صن هونج اكبر مطور عقارات في هونج
كونج فيما تسيطر كونج على نحو 41 و 53 من
مئه في المئه من اسهم الشركه ما يجعلها
اكبر مساهم في الشركه كما تتربع على ثروه
تقدر ب 14 مليارا و800 مليون دولار لكنما
مرت به يجعلها اليوم تبدو كسيده ب من ذات
الخرسانه والحديد اللذين نمت منهما ثروتها
الطائله